[Music]
just about everyone should be familiar
with the Planet of the Apes movie series
whether it's the classic movie from 1968
and its sequels or the three somewhat
more modern reboots from the 2010s after
the dark and very popular war of the
Planet of the Apes from 2017 we can soon
look forward to a new release we tell
you everything you need to know about
the upcoming action spectacle and hope
you enjoy our new Original
Episode as usual there is a possibility
of spoilers regarding the previous film
so be warned we can expect the story of
kingdom of the Planet of the Apes will
follow more or less directly from its
predecessor we recall at the end of the
third movie main character Caesar
succumbs to his wounds after saving his
tribe and defending it against an army
of humans War of the Planet of the Apes
was already rather dark and emotional
which fits perfectly with Caesar's quest
for Revenge which he undertakes after
his wife and son were murdered by humans
it can be assumed that Kingdom of the
Planet of the Apes will likewise follow
a similar pattern as we already know
from a first plot description by
deadline based on this the movie will
take place sometime after the events of
its predecessor as revealed by a casting
report the film which will be released
in 2024 will feature several ape
communities that have emerged from The
Oasis while a small group of humans have
slowly recovered from the ape flu
Caesar's Legacy is said to be ambivalent
while some ape communities have never
even heard of the hero others turn
history in their favor and establish
their own Empires based on false facts
due to this we can assume that some time
will have passed between part three and
part four
one of the many ape leaders is said to
be particularly ruthless and enslave
other Apes for his own purposes in order
to gain access to human technology the
main protagonist probably Cornelius
fights with all means for the freedom of
all apes and against their enslavement
along the way he meets a young human
woman who accompanies him it is not yet
known whether she like many of her kind
has become mute due to the flu as soon
as we have more details about the story
of kingdom of the Planet of the Apes we
will keep you
posted regarding the cast of Planet of
the Apes 4 there is already some info
thus for example we will see Caesar's
son Cornelius again who will be played
by Black Mirror actor Owen T apart from
him there are many confirmed actors with
unknown roles including newcomer Travis
Jeffrey the wincher star Freya Allen the
Orville actor Peter mon Jessica Jones
actor eeka darville and Kevin Durant who
played a part in the butterfly effect in
February The Hollywood Reporter also
revealed that Jurassic world Dominion
actress dykin lochman and Shameless star
William H M would be joining the cast
there is speculation that Macy will take
on the role of the villain which would
put him in good company with David ooo
Gary Oldman and Woody harelson from the
previous films it is considered almost
certain that Freya Allen will play the
protagonist's human companion while
Durant and Megan are believed to play
Apes for the other actors it is unclear
which side their characters will be on
filming on Kingdom of the Planet of the
Apes began in October 2022 in Sydney
Australia under the working title
forbidden zone and was already concluded
in mid-February 2023 the director this
time is West ball this is the first time
since Maze Runner 3 from 2018 that ball
has been back in the director's chair
the screenplay which was also penned by
ball was also contributed by Avatar 2
writer Josh Friedman according to Caesar
actor Andy Circus director West ball is
the perfect man for the job we can't
wait to see if the movie can keep that
promise apart from some artwork there
hasn't been much to see from the project
yet neither is there official news about
the first trailer so far since filming
has been done for for more than 3 months
many fans would like to see at least a
first trailer however one should not
disregard the fact the complex editing
of the footage has just begun after the
shooting was over with such a special
effects heavy movie that can definitely
take some time the previous movies are
considered Milestones of the performance
capture technique and the realistic
portrayal of the Apes and their emotions
always caused Great astonishment among
the audience it is to be expected that
the new movie will strive for a similar
quality the final result can be seen
next year Kingdom of the Planet of the
Apes is lated for a theatrical release
on May 24th
2024 please leave us a thumbs up if you
like this video also let us know in the
comments if you think the film series
has a shot at matching the success of
its predecessor even without Andy Circus
in the leading role thanks for watching
and see you next
[Music]
time